ALEX DANILO: All you web
developers out there follow me,
as I go to the other
side of the world
to talk to some graphics
experts about the insides
of modern browsers today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Alex Danilo.
I'm here in Winchester, the
home of the famous round table.
Now, King Arthur
may have long gone.
But we're bringing a whole
lot of graphic experts
from all around the world
to talk about the web.
So welcome to "The
Graphical Web."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm here with Cameron
McCormack from Mozilla.
And he's working on Firefox.
And today he gave a presentation
about colorful fonts
in OpenType that are
available in modern browsers.
Cameron, there are
three proposals.
There is one from
Microsoft, one from Google,
one from Mozilla and
Adobe working together.
The main one I found
interesting was SVG in OpenType.
So can you tell me what the
advantage of that is versus,
say, one of the other proposals?
CAMERON MCCORMACK:
Sure thing, Alex.
So to summarize the three
different proposals,
one was a bitmap format that
gets embedded into the font,
so they're PNGs--
that was the Google
proposal-- a proposal from
Microsoft, which had composed
glyphs from plain, flat shapes,
so regular OpenType glyphs.
And the third proposal,
from Mozilla and Adobe
was to embed SVG
documents into the font.
So with the SVG proposal,
you can use the full graphics
complexity of SVG to
render your glyphs.
So that means you can have
patterns in the fills.
You can use gradients,
animation on the glyphs as well.
ALEX DANILO: All right, great.
Also, I've seen in Japan quite
a lot of people using emojis,
like smileys and
things like that.
So is this what
this is aimed at?
CAMERON MCCORMACK:
Partially, yes.
So I think a lot of the
resurgence in interest
in chromatic fonts,
chromatic type,
has been emoji, which was sort
of popularized recently by iOS.
But of course, now
supported across
mobile and desktop
operating systems.
So emojis, since
they're little icons,
they probably have slightly
different requirements
from multicolored lettering.
So you might want to
choose a bitmap format
for those versus a
complex vector format.
But on the other
hand, the bitmaps
are not going to scale
particularly well.
So I think there are pros
and cons for both of them.
ALEX DANILO: Right, I get you.
And also, I've noticed
web developers always
struggle with different
kinds of devices,
like with a different
resolution screen.
So to me, I think
the SVG proposal
is a really good
approach towards that.
In fact, the Microsoft one
is quite interesting too.
So what are your thoughts
on the tons of pings,
like in the Google proposal?
Don't say anything bad thought.
CAMERON MCCORMACK: Yeah,
well so obviously for screens
with different DPIs and
just for showing the glyphs
at different sizes,
the scalable proposals
have a definite advantage
there to avoid pixelation.
There's probably a
speed difference.
Whereas, with the SVG proposal,
you need a whole SVG renderer.
It might be a bit slower than
the existing OpenType rendering
for glyphs the
Microsoft proposal uses.
And pings are probably pretty
fast to render as well.
So for fidelity, I
would still probably
go for one of the
scalable solutions, yeah.
ALEX DANILO: OK, great.
So web developers, look
forward to scalable graphics
in your fonts.
They're here now in Firefox.
They'll be coming other modern
browsers very soon, I expect,
so looking forward
to a colorful future.
Hi, I'm standing here
with Neil Trevett, who's
President of the Khronos Group.
Khronos, of course,
is the standards body
that produces things like
OpenGL, WebGL, OpenCL, WebCL,
et cetera.
And of course, we all know
WebGL is currently in browsers.
So Neil, where do you see the
future of hardware acceleration
on the web and
graphics in general?
NEIL TREVETT: I think there's
a great feature for it.
And I think it's going
to be at two levels.
We have to remember that all the
browser vendors are using GPUs
under the covers, the
composition, the rendering.
But I think your question
is talking about the APIs
that developers
can use themselves.
And WebGL, as you say,
is now very pervasive.
We're expecting it
to be everywhere
on desktop and mobile.
And we hope the next
one will be WebCL,
which is for compute,
as opposed to graphics.
ALEX DANILO: Right.
Also, I've seen that
the trend in tablets
these days is much higher
resolution screens.
So do you see that
trend continuing?
Do you think that
this would mean
silicon is much more
important as we go forward?
NEIL TREVETT: Yeah, it's already
been a tremendous increase
in the number of pixels
that have to be processed.
From the original iPhone
to now the iPad mini,
it's a 20-times increase
in the number of pixels.
That's an enormous
number of pixels
to process and to push
around in a system.
And if you have to
do that on the CPU,
not only is it going to be
not snappy and buttery smooth
on the screen, it's going
to eat your battery.
So there's a double win
for bringing this rendering
off the CPU onto the GPU.
It goes faster, and your
battery will last longer.
ALEX DANILO: So for the
web developers out there,
if they were going to
get started with WebGL,
what would you
recommend they do?
Do they learn raw WebGL?
Do they jump in one of
the JavaScript libraries?
Or what would you
think they should do?
NEIL TREVETT: If they're
already a 3D developer
and they know
OpenGL, yes, they'll
find WebGL very familiar.
And it will be very easy to
come up the learning curve.
If you're coming
into it fresh, I
would start with one of the
proven middleware libraries,
because they can really
ease the learning curve.
Now, three.js is
one of the easiest.
There's a new one, Babylon.js.
And actually, there are a
bunch of them out there.
And depending on what
kind of application
you're trying to
do, sometimes you'll
find ones that are targeted
just to your kind of community.
So Google around, find
the middleware library
that best suits your needs.
The default perhaps is
three.js, and start with that.
You'll probably find you can
get a long way, before you need
to start figuring
out more details.
ALEX DANILO: OK, wonderful.
Thanks very much
for that insight,
and we're looking forward
to a great hardware
accelerated future on the Web.
NEIL TREVETT: Yes.
ALEX DANILO: Now, Brian and
I have been working together
on the web animation spec,
which I'm really excited about.
So I just wanted
to ask Brian, what
do you see that web animations
does for the general web
developer?
BRIAN BIRTLES: It probably
does about two things.
I guess, first of all,
it gives developers
access to the animation
functionality of the browser.
So the browser can do
optimizations that you cannot
do in JavaScript, such as
running things on another
thread.
And so it gives
developers access to that.
It also let's developers peek
into what the browser is doing
with their regular CSS
animations and so on,
so they can inspect why
their CSS isn't working.
And they can also
tweak it as well
and extend it in ways they
couldn't do otherwise.
In addition to that, it
explains what's going on.
We have CSS, and we've got SVG.
And this is a common model that
explains what both of those
are doing, so that
developers can
make the transition between
different technologies,
as they need to.
ALEX DANILO: So we already
have small animation in SVG.
And we have CSS animations
and transitions.
So what actually happens
with Web Animations?
Does it bring the
model together?
Or they incompatible?
How does it actually
work under the hood?
BRIAN BIRTLES: Yeah,
so basically, we've
tried to work out what are the
common features between the two
and base the model
around that side.
So it's feature
complete, with regards
to everything in
both CSS and SVG.
It's the union of those two.
And then we aim to
just layer CSS and SVG
as kind of syntactical
layers on top of that.
So it's really just
the one unified one
model for both of them.
ALEX DANILO: OK, great.
Now I know that
Chrome has actually
implemented Web
Animations, and we've
seen some really great
performance improvements
on demos.
So are we going to see this
in Firefox anytime soon?
BRIAN BIRTLES: Yeah,
I'm working on it.
So bits have already
landed in nightly.
And it's coming
along with Firefox.
We're on a different
subsets to Chrome initially.
But yeah, we're definitely
have in sites the same subset
that Chrome has
already released.
So yes, you can expect
that someday soon.
ALEX DANILO: All right, cool.
So let me just ask you.
What about other browsers?
Do you think it'll
come to other browsers?
BRIAN BIRTLES: I hope so.
I really hope so.
And I think, in the interim,
we can use a polyfill
to work around that,
although it may not
get quite the same performance.
But I think there's a lot
of good reasons for browsers
to implement that, both in
terms of exposing animation
through their dev
tools, but also
just in order to keep
up with the performance
that they'll be sitting
in Chrome and Firefox.
ALEX DANILO: Awesome.
Gets started on Web
Animations today.
It's usable.
It's native in Chrome.
It's coming in Firefox.
Soon, every browser should
have it, fingers crossed.
And yeah, give it a go.
This year's conference,
Frank, there's
been a lot of focus on
hardware accelerated approaches
to web performance
and web graphics.
So Internet Explorer
9, 10, and 11
have really embraced
hardware acceleration.
So one of the things
you spoke about
was how IE breaks up
the layers in a web page
and then uses the underlying
OS to do the compositing.
Can you talk a little
bit about how that works?
FRANK OLIVIER: So we
have an OS compositer
that we use that renders
all the IE content.
It's a very nice way for us
to make the browser very, very
fast and enable some key
scenarios, like a SVG filter
hardware acceleration,
for example.
So this is a nice way for us to,
starting with IE 9 and IE 10,
set the scene for building a
nice and fast touch-friendly
mobile browser.
ALEX DANILO: All
right, excellent.
And another feature that I
thought was really interesting
was, that currently,
the IE 11 actually
enables YCbCr JPEG support.
So it actually sends YCbCr to
the GPU, instead of RGB data.
Now, that is aimed at
reducing memory bandwidth.
So how does a web developer
actually use that feature?
FRANK OLIVIER: It's
actually very simple.
All you need to do in Photoshop,
when yoy do File, Save As JPEG,
is just set the compression
to between 0 and 50.
And that will do that setting.
Or there's also a tool
called RIOT, Radical Image
Optimization Tool.
And that can do the
subsampling for you as well.
ALEX DANILO: Excellent.
And also, we all know the
multiscreen world is here--
mobile phones, tablets, and
desktops, and everything.
So how does IE address it, as
far as a compatibility features
thing?
Across the different
devices, how does that work?
FRANK OLIVIER: So
like other browsers,
I think, we have a
very big interest
in keeping the web platform
the same across all devices.
So we run the same code
across all devices.
When we did WebGL, we did
it on the desktop first.
And we compiled it for
mobile in one afternoon.
So it's the same code
running in the same place.
ALEX DANILO: OK, brilliant.
Well, lovely to hear about it.
There you go, web developers.
Shrink you JPEGs,
using the YCbCr.
It will save you
space on your site.
It will run faster as a
result and work beautifully
in all browsers.
Now, Eric, there's
a lot of graphics
that's been happening
in this conference.
There's SVG.
And there's Canvas.
And there's WebGL.
I understand you're the chair
of the SVG working group.
So as a web developer, where
would you use SVG, as opposed,
to say, Canvas.
And what are the
advantages of it?
ERIK DAHLSTROM: So one
of the main use cases
we see right now is
icons and scalable vector
resources for
websites, for icons,
for imagery that's meant
to be panned and zoomed.
This is one use case that
SVG is supremely suited
for, as an image format,
which Canvas isn't.
The other thing, I guess,
is smaller interactive web
applications.
Say you have a seating for a
theater or something like that.
You have a seating
plan, and you want
to be able to pick some seats.
You need to know
where seats are,
and it's easy, if it's
available in a document itself.
Just add event listeners
as you would in HTML.
So for applications that
aren't that complicated,
with a relatively low
number of elements,
that's a good use case for SVG.
Whereas, if you
have graphics that
require you to draw
a lot of elements,
you have billions of
rectangles or points.
Then Canvas is much
more suitable for that.
ALEX DANILO: That makes sense.
And also, I know the
SVG working group
has been working hard on SVG 2.
So web developers
have now become
accustomed to SVG 1, which
is in all the browsers.
But SVG 2 is coming.
So can you tell us roughly
what SVG 2 brings to the table.
ERIK DAHLSTROM: So
SVG 2 is continuing
the work we did with SVG
1.1 Second Edition, which
is basically trying
to smooth over
all of the gaps between
HTML and CSS and SVG,
so making the platform
a bit more consistent,
dropping certain
things that we have
in 1.1, which no longer apply.
We had interfaces, for example,
for pausing the rendering,
to be able to update lots
of elements in a DOM tree.
Turns out, browsers these
days optimize for this anyway.
So those interfaces don't apply.
They don't do anything
useful anymore.
So we could remove those.
And it's clean-ups like that.
And we're also trying to promote
more of the existing attributes
to properties, so
that you can style
like the width of a
rectangle with CSS, which
makes doing certain
things easier.
ALEX DANILO: OK.
And do you ever see SVG being
hardware accelerated in Blink?
ERIK DAHLSTROM: Yes, I think
that's the way of the future.
I mean, it's always
going to have
to have some parts like a
fall-back in software anyway.
But certain things--
it's coming.
It's going to be there.
ALEX DANILO: So this
seems to be a recurring
theme at the conference,
hardware exhilaration
for everything,
especially mobile.
Well, there you have it.
That was "The Graphical Web."
And these guys are building
better and better browsers just
for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]